[Music]
all right what's up everybody good
morning I just finished a morning
meeting with Michael and we're meeting
about our independent movie scripts that
were writing outside of JK work we I
it's been a lot of time writing my own
stuff too we're keeping each other
accountable for the year and have
conducting our own meetings so that we
can keep each other moving forward with
progress and things like that because
otherwise I'll sit on an idea and just
sit on it and never write anything and
I'm just sitting there thinking about it
and it just sits there and it's thought
about and that's the extent of my
writing meeting it with someone to talk
things over especially if you if you're
having writer's block is really really
good for the life of that project gonna
be doing more of those meetings today's
are really weird day though because we
met at a cafe that we normally meet at
it's always open for seven days a week
four days a week seven days a week it's
open and today it was closed
it was nice huh I get no recognition
yeah no copy ID copy copyright Content
ID yeah so me and Michael meet up at
that cafe right we always meet up at and
they were closed and I thought it was
weird and turns out that they're closing
because of the OCO giving yeah so yeah
so I figure I was in refresh off of the
news of Kobe yeah
Mamba Monday others are calling it the
other hash hanging at Mamba Monday and
yesterday is when the whole tragic news
happened and like I don't know today I
woke up this morning like feeling like
am I still dreaming did that yeah I
can't believe that happened
yeah the whole city of La is like in
mourning apparently multiple restaurants
are closed today because la is morning
like you could feel it like you could
really feel the atmosphere it's like
that
I even tweeted it to I said like it just
it felt like nodding your throat feeling
but like everywhere like you could feel
it in the atmosphere like la is
heartbroken and I'm freaking heartbroken
too cuz I grew up you know like born and
raised in LA so my whole childhood was
like Shaq and Kobe I didn't even watch
basketball but I knew all about Shaq and
Kobe cuz they were like the dream team
and you know like I went to the 2010
Laker parade Kobe is LA and they're just
so sad that he's passed and like his
daughters gone too and it's just so
heartbreaking yesterday Casey and I were
crying
we're like hugging and crying we're just
like cuz for KCI me why is it important
to you oh man I'm getting emotional
right now
so mute if we're talking yesterday first
of all I knew this is Kobe's the first
celebrity I ever cried for in the phone
upon hearing his death okay you're human
don't fight it
I know I think I've cried a lot you
should be someone like all dried up but
I know ya watched a lot of Kobe videos
and like not even like highlight videos
from his basketball just like interviews
and like do I really have lost it
whenever you're watching that clip of
him talking in the traffic mm-hmm get
yourself together man it's okay you have
to be strong
Oh at least yeah so yeah so Kobe like
I've never been a fan of Kobe per se
because I was a Dallas Mavericks man
growing up and the Lakers have always
been like the team that would always get
Mavericks like you're just Americans
could not be I mean I feel like every
team has is to say every fan of another
team from another city has this say
about Kobe so I wasn't a Kobe thing
because they would always kill my team I
think that's pretty universal he's that
good
but when when I heard about his passing
like I don't know I just a rush from
emotions came out why I think it's
because um
he's just so embedded his greatness is
so embedded into like the pop culture
mm-hmm and like the the social fabric of
our reality yeah you know but you can
never really hate the guy you know he's
just cool dude he's a cool dude and my
gum
damn I'm not your family it's okay baby
you're so sweet yes such a big heart
yeah I think this is the first celebrity
venom it has passed on that um I
register as part of my childhood like
this guy came into the scene when I was
like 9 or 10 yeah and so throughout like
the parts of your childhood that's
actually the part that you hold on to
the most like my high school years
that's when I became a really really big
basketball fan and he was just you know
he's Kobe you know I think he was just
always part of that and so when someone
like that passes on especially so iconic
like that I think it's kind of like like
it's like also the death of your
childhood it's like the death of your
yeah like a piece of you goes with him
yeah I don't know makes you feel very
mortal feels very young makes it feel
like life is really fleeting and
[Music]
nothing's guaranteed yeah this cop he's
not supposed to go out like that I know
it's so tragic and his daughter oh yeah
I don't know it's like you know
celebrity suicide that's one thing to
deal with but it's like there's like
some sort of some weird form of like
comfort when you know that they like
asked for it I guess and Rakow be it's
like it was meant to be just another car
ride you know to his daily doings and
take his daughter to a basketball game
yeah and they're just I don't know you
know so yeah yesterday we did absolutely
nothing yeah yesterday we're supposed to
work on the house and like pack up some
more stuff and wait like just waking up
to that news I'm like this isn't real
I'm still dreaming
I'm still
this is it yeah yeah it's been crazy
this morning - I woke up and I'm like
does the world even go on like that's
how it feel it's like it just feels
crazy now like you got me cranked it
yeah I don't know I feel so bad for like
all the families - because they were it
wasn't just coping and Gianna like there
were a mother a father and like their
daughter yeah a lot and then more and
then there was that like yeah they were
you do just so many families affected by
this it's just so tragic it's so so
tragic I do have a big mood meeting and
I don't know just try to liven things up
I'm gonna get a little bit excited about
this we have our big mood merge yeah I
don't know when this is coming out you
have a big heart you do baby but I don't
know when this is gonna come out but
hopefully it comes out before
Valentine's Day so if you're watching
this before Valentine's Day this is a
limited release design that we will
never ever have again so hopefully you
can get one and if this is posted after
Valentine's Day then I'm sorry you
missed out but anyway I have a meeting
to go to you what are you gonna do I'm
going to write you know I thought about
and I really can't get the scoby thing
on my mind I so it's so weird to me that
I am so emotional Darden's
it's not the expected thing that we
thought I would get emotional about but
yeah I feel like part of the mourning
process for me is I want to play in b2k
hmm as Kobe it's like you're remembering
yeah I just want to like I want to just
use them in the game and just like yeah
coquí's doe yeah I never cared for
playing with Kobe as Kobe in any game
I'm like Kobe is not as he's my rival
and you know the older I get the more
like I feel like I'm just a softie yeah
yeah I feel like I've always been a
softie but I cam yeah more of a softie
now no you know what it is it's that
when you're young your ego is too
inflated and you're you have to be like
too cool for school
always like no
who you are in society hands down youth
is all about putting up a front and like
putting up a mask and just try to be
just gotta be like just being proud
shoulder yeah for everything so then out
you're the older we get cuz I feel it
too like the older we get the more we
are okay with like just being us and
just being like hey I don't have to be
like this I don't have to be a certain
type of whatever true if this was five
years ago ten years ago if I started
crying and I cut delete do it again dry
eyes man up dude come on yeah I think
that's the thing too like like for
example for me over the years and I know
I don't know if I've mentioned this in a
previous vlog but anyway over the years
I've realized like looking at our older
videos I have been I used to be like a
lot more excited a lot more high-energy
a lot more like vibrant and lively and
that was because there were a lot of
things that were like factoring into why
I acted like that and then compared to
now like how I'm currently kind of
monotone very low-energy obviously I
mean we're talking about some heavy
stuff too but just in general and all of
our vlogs like I don't I don't like
exert as much energy as I used to and I
think because as time has progressed and
the longer we've had this channel like
the more I've like just settling in and
getting comfortable and I'm just being
able to be comfortable with the camera
and like showing Who I am on the daily
basis like normally I'm a very
low-energy kind of person unless we're
like traveling or something and I get
really excited and that's when you'll
see me see it get crazier so it's real
when you travel yeah yeah the lies it's
like I mean not that it's fake
excitement because I really was excited
like in the earlier years of this vlog
channel like I really was excited cuz
I'm like this is something new and plus
like I was super afraid of like talking
into a lens like it was just the most
frightening thing ever so like I think I
kind of like had to psych myself out and
be like extra whatever but it's not that
it was fake it was just like a different
version of myself
and now this is the version of me that I
am and this is what I convey and same
with you like in front of the camera
used to be a lot different compared to
what you are now yeah used to be like
want to be like really witty and like
really like like ah
zinger you know whatever and no no no no
it's just like it's too much work to be
witty and zingers here in there just
kind of like it's really about me I feel
like any time anyone's on camera means I
think it still comes out today like for
me it's like whenever cameras are on you
kind of there's always this idea in the
back of mine that goes oh I put on the
version of yourself that you wish you
were you nosey cooler or whatever you
know like this cool factor you know and
I don't know maybe it's a combination of
getting older and then like and just
having done this for so long now that
like I don't feel obligated to like need
to put on a front anymore yeah but not
to say that was a too much of a front
either a fake version right there was
just like a heightened like like you
just like me you go on a first date or
like you're you're trying to make a good
impression with someone it's not like
you're trying to be fake right your
heightened at a point where you're like
I need to impress this person and so I
think in the beginning of the vlog count
for example it's like there was like
this first impression kind of thing
where it's like get to know me guys and
you want to be like a bull and all these
things yeah now we've been in this
five-year relationship guys I'm talking
to you guys down there and I was like
we've been in a five-year relationship
now I don't feel like I need to know it
could fart in front of you yeah we're
just getting older to true because you
know like I could totally relate to
thing that you're saying to about like
needing to make a good first impression
because for me my my mindset when
filming for this channel has over
been like oh this is for our future
memories like one day when I'm older my
kids are me or my kids and my grandkids
are gonna view this footage and they're
gonna get to see like a day in the life
of their ancestor or whatever it's so
like I would always be like okay I gotta
show them the best and that's always
been like my driving forces thinking of
my future self or future family members
viewing this and that's always been the
the reason why I kind of have this um
yeah like needing to put do like a good
first impression like needing to be
happy and excited cuz I don't like I'm
so excited that you future people are
viewing me you know like I don't know
it's just it's a weird thing you know
every dynamic I don't know but but it's
a true version of yourself is because
it's how you feel at the time too so
yeah yeah anyway sorry for the crying
session sorry for bringing wait why are
you apologizing we're just saying we're
being unapologetically ourselves Oh true
sorry not sorry let's cry some more
[Laughter]
[Music]
these flowers yeah oh man they're really
extras always very lovely but like those
ones those ones are still alive yeah
these are nice mm-hmm
and these are pretty fresh they're very
fresh and then I'm I didn't pick these
out true they're these are they're so
fresh they're they're an apology from
the other day
there I'm sorry flowers not just because
flowers yeah I messed up the other day
yeah pretty bad I thought you guys yeah
that's pretty intense true maybe maybe
maybe a different video then when we
will make a video later these are not
apology flowers by the way these I don't
I don't mess up that often guys I mean
you do but you don't
oh really is a good a good burn okay
fine hey does it sound like I have a
lisp it does a little bit thank you for
being your mouth no it's so swollen that
I have my lips don't wrap around to
touch each other as well as they
supposed to and then it affects my my
tongue placement - it's weird
[Music]
true true true after my surgery they
gave me an ice packs which I did not use
I didn't realize how important it was
you did and then and then I was such a
bad receiver of ice packs that you prep
a bad husband that I just left it on
tables everywhere yeah bad self-care
work for yourself true I'm a good
husband because I care for you a lot
great husband okay bye
right here on top of the staircase this
is what I do all the time when you leave
I sit right here i watch you put on your
shoes I do that all right
know sometimes and then watch you go
into your car over there all righty it
has been a productive day just some
writing today this one would be watching
today I guess it's not that productive
but I got something done and uh BAM look
who's home you're frozen like the
freezer you hungry yeah frozen dumplings
[Music]
mm-hmm the typical enter meeting they
finished and now they're shopping food
wardrobe tonight I was feeling lazy so I
didn't I didn't want to cook or anything
so we're doing hot pot hot pot it's
always like this healthy alternative to
cooking where you don't really have to
do a whole lot of prep work the only
thing I did was maybe chop up these
vegetables boiled his water and then
this meat is pre-cut from the store and
then we have some leftover rice order
Thai food a couple days ago and I
leftover fried rice I thought huh this
will be the carb got some protein some
veggies simple but it's a pretty yet
balanced meal I would say yep yep what's
your favorite thing about a hotpot no in
like a couple seconds do you enjoy the
process of cooking your own food
yeah or do you prefer going to
restaurants or having the experience or
just having food
done-for-you and just eat it look you
like both oh interestings and you are
mature enough to appreciate both aspects
of it not one is greater than any other
yep oh wow
very very mature of you I think I would
think I always think it's so interesting
to see you grow up eating such an Asian
type of cuisine because on the outside I
see a brown boy
and put on the inside of you once you
get to know you you're very very much
Asian you know how to use chopsticks
chopsticks like a mofo you appreciate
hotpot Korean barbecue careful my
profession it's very very hot man how do
you feel about your upbringing but you
don't know I need you no you don't see
it as anything weird right because it's
doing your upbringing is the only
experience you've ever had yeah yeah do
you ever compare yourself to your
friends at school or anything like that
no never no never
it's like you have like Mexican friends
at school but then you have Asian
friends at school but then like you kind
of relate to the Asian kids more
sometimes but big in your life but I
also have my Mexican side so I relate to
the Mexican kids more too sometimes
yeah it's like back and forth
[Music]
for health reasons I think I like this
better but flavor-wise Korean barbecue
for sure I feel like this is way more
healthier because when you cook the meat
in here and you see the fat foam up on
the top mm-hmm
I feel like when you mean pull the meat
out it looks like you're kind of rinsing
it off of the excess fat so it's like a
cleaner bite of protein I don't know if
that's true momisa do you like it when I
call you mommy or baby or TIFF I like
all of it because it's you addressing me
mm-hmm
how about pumpkin yeah you tried that
one didn't really stick we had an error
stuck I tried doing it for a little bit
but yeah what would you call your future
wife I don't know honey honey I tried
calling you honey - and then just like
sick we're just not the nickname kind of
people we really aren't and I wish you
were sometimes I'm like all of you so
cute yeah if there was a nickname I
would want to call you I think monkey so
cute but your ex-girlfriend used to call
you that so I want to call you that I
like being called monkey I identify with
a monkey because my ears stick out mmm
you know I feel like when people do
monkey things like that ears stick out I
don't know and I have big ears and I
don't know and then for a long time my
favorite animal was a monkey like oh I
can like Chinese folklore like The
Monkey King for some reason I really
liked that like folklore your the years
a dragon man that's like so badass like
what's another is a dragon in Spanish I
mean it Spanish Chinese alone
Bruce Lee his nickname his name in
Chinese was lazy alone li little dragon
is how it translated so it's pretty sick
what I see what you're saying what is it
oh we're playing NBA 2k crazy
well not hold on to me let me roll it on
here you faked his death I don't know
it's pretty official it's like we said
earlier I feel like a proprietary then
it is for me I feel like I really want
to play in be 2k and I really want to
play as Kobe and that's what we're gonna
do we're gonna play some basketball yeah
yeah you never grew up with basketball
in your life ever
until recently I got back into
basketball but like we don't ever really
even talk about basketball and then
Kobe's also one generation before you
how do you feel about it all it's pretty
devastating yeah yeah I remember always
saying when I was playing basketball
with my cousin's oh yeah Kobe and I'm
always making oh really yeah it gives
you the power gives me the power you
know hearing
it's kind of sad a lot of people are
saying it'll never be the same when you
do the the paper ball Kobe trash can
true true I'm really surprised this
really affected us that much I know it's
crazy okay
the only other celebrity death that
really got to me was Robin Williams
mm-hmm but for him like when I found out
I was just shocked and I cried because
he was like my childhood and then I move
done like the next day I'm like Deena
sucks but like no man like it's been a
really a whole 24 hours like I could
easily cry about Kobe right now true I
keep thinking about it too I get every
the moment I look at my phone I think
about it it's weird I know and then I
keep scrolling through social media and
seeing like r.i.p Kobe and I'm just like
I can't like my brain can't process it I
just can well we are going to finish
this vlog with some NBA 2k gameplay
footage and I'm gonna play us Kobe ready
yep let's do it oh yeah we should
Kobe against Kobe hi everyone from two K
sports
[Applause]
it'll be Los Angeles off the chip
east X now abdul-jabbar forward now
let's check out our starter you're
supposed to do the eight-second
violation or the 24-second shot clock
golden yeah you're yellow okay I have to
teach you about basketball we are going
to be a basketball family starting now
oh they know all your shoots like Kobe
oh man games are crazy nowadays Showtime
all time Magic Johnson Randy roxxon's
another legendary basketball player I
like how they just shoot shirts oh yeah
they actually do that game mm-hmm I know
but I never got tickets that were cool
enough to actually get those shirts and
I used to go to basketball games
they're expensive shirts considering you
had to sit in the in the lower areas to
get entertainment even have a chance to
get the shirts look why is Kobe good at
defending stop defending me Kobe so I
some score is Kobe oh no you guys you
stranded three
catchin up alright let's just run the
clock in commemoration for Kobe all
right 24 seconds our AP Kobe hey yeah
you get on the inner let it run it run
run 20 45 for is what all the team's ago
- salute Kobi babies really bad was it
every job and with that we're in this
video yeah rest in peace Toby rest in
peace
[Music]
[Music]